big mood what does it mean I may be out
of the loop and registered completely
uncool by pretty much everyone on the
internet but I'd like to think that I
keep up pretty well with the Linguistics
of today's youth everyone has started to
scream at the top of their lungs at
random cliff Heights or if I post a
picture that has a certain sour
expression a big mood if I'm talking
about something that somebody can relate
to big mood detective markiplier is on
the job here to discover exactly what
big mood means its origin and what it
could mean for you and your family is
big mood coming to kill you where you
sleep tonight that's what we're gonna
find out these are a lot of very
important questions to answer markiplier
why thank you very much I'd like to
think of a contributing member of
society that uh oh no that's wrong big
GG big big mood big nude what does big
nude give me two big nude no no I want
big nude
[Laughter]
all righty then I don't think that's
right I think something very wrong with
that I don't think that's anybody's big
mood but big mood what is big mood what
is this you stay positive you always
believe that everything is going to work
out how do you do it well I'll tell you
my secret sir my self I say everything's
gonna be ok
and I don't know how much longer I can
do it
all right then thank you skittles
skittles juice for that one but not what
I'm looking for big mood Urban
Dictionary the one source of information
I can trust in this world see excuse me
just went through puberty a little bit
more see it's relatively new and not a
lot of people know about it people keep
talking about it relatable said in
response to something that you agree
with it sounds like something that a
caveman would say in response to
something like his fresh kill unga-bunga
brought home the biggest I hear this
joke I'm going for Unga Bunga brought
home the biggest saber-tooth Tiger today
[Music]
big mood that doesn't help me here we go
even a reddit post doesn't know what big
mood means pistol responds Lizzie
I'll break it down this way big is for
the amount of mood obviously while mood
refers to the way you feel right so this
hypothetical detective is the link is
saying dead body in the corner that's
how I'm feeling very much in short big
mood Eagles I feel pretty dead do mr.
Cooper oops wait here's a detective
walking up look at a dead body ok first
of all big mood let's back your hundred
and fifty thousand notes how I think I
gotta go to the root form of mood mood
[Music]
first videos closer to the truth just
shut up shut up one goddamn second stop
booting me up no answers from me no
answers to anything I don't understand
I don't know what's going on I think I
gotta ask you guys you guys have never
let me down before you guys whatever I
ask you something you take it honestly
you answer me correctly yeah quickly and
I appreciate every single time you do
because it always fills me and so
appropriately and then I'm not left out
of the loop I'm just gonna ask what does
it mean just a simple question right
what is big mood B 1-800 are you
slapping you are not helping no a mood
that's thank you know dot Lauren no God
Lauren no Doubt's like saying I feel you
I don't wanna feel anybody l'm a mood
what you can't define a word with the
word how you feel but big hi that's
pretty close to it I think I think
you're getting closer there big move big
move big boot big d mood mood big moon
big mood like you feel something like
hard and in the fields you feel no no I
don't feel you're not knowing what it
means that's a big mood your moon but
it's big something you relate to so much
it's your mood the opposite of a small
mood is depression and acceptable answer
yes this thank Y in fact that is know
now why is this so jpg how many times
has this been screened shaft
okay I got that saved I just need it
that's why I needed to do that for a
second save that for later don't worry
about it Lowell opposite of small move I
refused to explain a meme to you do you
really want to know it really means some
of you relate to you tell you to I don't
want to tell you I can't tell you if I
don't know when your emotional state is
significantly enlarged by a given amount
dependent on the magnitude of your
situation it means that the matriarchal
figure that lives in the center of the
earth is sending out wavelengths so bit
that we're both so that we're all
feeling the same emotions is called a
big mood because a larger big portion of
the population is it feeling it the mood
together huge relateable you mean this
that's not what it means
it mood no that's my big but something
you'll understand when you get tall I'm
not getting to the meat of the matter I
don't think big mood can be translated
through text please send me a video of
yourself explaining what big mood means
or is or does in five seconds or less I
got I don't have a lot of time for this
song I need your help very serious
that's a little desperate there we go
people will get that people will
understand that it's gonna take people a
while so I'm gonna kill some time
[Music]
there should be answers by now it's like
when you subscribe you crank gameplays
do it now why you have bigger easy what
that doesn't make no why does everyone
talk about big minutes why not small Moo
it's like why not medium music cuz no
one gives a that's why
[Music]
Oh clever and Rijal oh my god smooth
crying a big mood is when you
get eleven chicken nuggets in a ten
piece order perfect explanation big mood
is a big mood the definition is in the
words that's not how it works you lazy
piece of crap it's when you relate to
something extremely thank you thank you
[Music]
I don't know about that one
Oh big mood is the spirit it's a feeling
state of mind that's perfect thank you
Oh Oh big mood when you describe it in
food look of course I get it big mood is
a cooler way of saying hashtag relatable
is it cooler is it cooler is it cooler
is it no oh oh oh I'll picture diagram
wait a minute wait no no did you tell me
this already this thing booed me to
sound like this okay you know I've seen
enough okay all right I think I properly
understand what big mood means big mood
so I don't know if you guys agree with
that let me don't actually don't let me
know down in the comments below let me
know down the mood section down below
let me know if this video is deserving
of a great big food and don't bail don't
ring the bell for more videos
blast Bigley the bugle horn of mood and
thanks again for watching and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
[Music]